youtuber i show speed has been banned
from all riot games after a clip went
viral of him making misogynistic
comments in a valorum match the whole
thing has been blowing up on twitter and
big names have weighed in like xqc
michaela and keemstar here's everything
you need to know
i show speed is a variety streamer on
youtube now if you recognize him but
haven't watched his streams before
there's a good chance it was from a clip
of one of his incredibly popular omegle
streams that's crazy bro i like you you
you crazy i'm a big fan of you bro
really
yeah big fan man what i stream on again
bro
he's also known for streaming games
valerian and nb2k being two of his most
popular titles to play his streams are
irreverent chaotic and certainly not to
everyone's taste but he's clearly very
popular given that he's currently
sitting at over seven million
subscribers on youtube most of speed's
rise to fame has been in the past year
particularly since the start of 2022 and
this platform has allowed him to put out
music videos to large audiences that
have racked up tens of millions of views
[Music]
but for many people their first
introduction to speed may have been last
wednesday it was then that full squad
gaming's jake lucky tweeted out saying i
now understand why valor and cues are so
unbelievably toxic you get one of the
most popular streamers on youtube i show
speed saying crap like this and getting
nothing but praise and laughs crap is
whack this video does contain some very
strong language which some may find
disturbing calm down damn bruh shut up
bruh i know how to play this game i'm
not a noob all right god damn
dude
what [ __ ] [ __ ] is a [ __ ] talking to
me is a female talking to me am i yo no
no am i tripping am i tripping
it's a female talking to me right now
over the next few hours the clip blew up
it's currently sitting at over 9.1
million views and has garnered over 40
000 replies and quote tweets one of
those who replied was violent producer
sarah dadafsha who said this is a huge
yikes and we do not want players like
this in our community at all i went
ahead and permabanned this player from
ballarant as well as all other riot
games thanks for raising this please
keep raising stuff like this and
reporting so we can make valorant safer
youtube's global head of gaming creators
lester chen simply replied on it
although we've heard no official ruling
from youtube on the matter now one clip
that did appear a lot in the replies was
of speed himself being subjected to
racist abuse in valorem one user stated
why not also show what he has to go
through not defending what he did
because they're both wrong but the
game's just a toxic environment so
people act like it
bro where's the clean water i'm trying
to figure out how to heal the game can
you just tell me how to heal in the game
just heal like a woman only the white
characters can heal
yeah only only the
the white characters can heal i'm sorry
now by this point a lot of big names
were getting involved one of the largest
conversations was between xqc and drama
alert founder keemstar keemstar referred
to the original clip shared by jake
lucky as a case of trash talk he then
shared some screenshots of tweets made
by jake in which he praised trash talk
in different games such as call of duty
and valorent he also alleged that people
were saying the reason for jake lucky's
initial tweet was racially motivated but
didn't elaborate further xqc replied to
state that what was said by speed to the
girl was less trash talk and simply an
example of blatant sexism but away from
this periphery argument many people just
wanted to hear from speed himself he
shared a video on twitter titled sorry
to explain his side of things what's
good um everybody um it's a clip you
know that i've seen you know that's
going crazy right now uh me between an
altercation with a girl
and i was playing violent you know what
i'm saying and i want to say some you
know like a few things from that uh
situation you know what i'm saying but
that day um you know i wasn't having a
good day you know i was getting a lot of
racist takes of speech donations a lot
of people you know talking about my dead
aunt that's in the grave right now but
look i don't want to make that no excuse
i'm wrong you know what i'm saying i'm
not i'm not trying to justify you know
what i'm saying
i'm just saying like that day i just
don't bash on people for no reason
that's why that's where i'm coming from
from that speed went on to say that he
was completely wrong for saying what he
did but wanted to make it clear that
firstly he's still young that the clip
was from months ago and that he's grown
in the time since but some twitter users
were quick to point out an allegedly
more recent clip from gta of him using
similar language which his defenders
claimed was just role-playing
in the initial video most people would
agree that what was said goes a lot
further than simple trash talk i think a
fair definition of trash talk is when
you insult someone's ability to play the
game or try and psych them out but it
definitely doesn't include insulting
them based on their gender so we know
that speed has been banned from all riot
games now and we may see measures taken
against him on youtube these allegations
of misogyny come just weeks after the
jason r drama where the valor and
streamer was accused of misogyny for
refusing to play games with women
streamers michaela and ludwig got into a
debate about whether or not the valorem
producer should have announced speeds
banned so publicly michaela argued that
riot tweeted the ban for social
engagement while they've recently
settled a 100 million dollar settlement
for sexual harassment they also
disagreed on what steps riot is taking
to improve their ban system michaela
said there's been no improvement while
ludwig argued there has and toxicity is
a wider problem which other big
platforms are dealing with too riot have
talked in the past about cracking down
on toxicity in january they shared the
steps they've been taking including
muting 400 000 players that month who
exhibited signs of abusive text or voice
chat they also announced their future
plans including harsher punishments
real-time tax moderation and initial but
as of yet unspecified steps to detect
toxicity in voice comms so this whole
situation has brought up a lot of
questions that you're probably familiar
with if you're into gaming or have
simply been online in the past five
years what constitutes a joke or trash
talk when does that line get crossed and
who decides where the line is should the
age of the offender be taken into
account how much responsibility lies on
game developers to stamp out toxic
behavior and are companies doing enough
to combat it if there's one thing for
certain it's that this situation has
raised a lot of questions and even more
opinions on it let me know what you
think
you